i
hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france en 24 soy santiago aristiga y en
esta emisión vamos a hablar sobre el
activismo gordo y por eso saludamos y
agradecemos muchísimo su presencia a lux
moreno ella es filósofa escritora y
representante del activismo gordo y por
la diversidad corporal es autora del
libro gorda vanidosa sobre la gordura en
la era del espectáculo lux moreno
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24
a ustedes por haber mencionado bueno en
primer lugar preguntarle qué es el
activismo gordo como surge que lucha y
qué necesidades acompaña
bueno el equipo a bordo es un activismo
que se centra en desmantelar lo que van
a hacer las opresiones y violencias
sobre los cuerpos que específicamente
aparecen porque hay jerarquías
corporales que hacen más valiosos los
cuerpos delgados que los cuerpos gordos
en este sentido hay una discriminación
sistemática contra las corporalidad es
gordas y vamos a ver que no es sólo
contra la corporalidad de gordas que se
llama gordo fobia y que afecta digamos
la calidad de vida de las personas que
tienen corporalidad es diversas es decir
diferentes a la norma que la norma
vendría a ser la habilidades
ahora looks algo que está bueno aclarar
porque no van a faltar quien diga estás
haciendo una entrevista sobre activismo
gordo entrevistando a una persona flaca
con una belleza hegemónica policías del
cuerpo no quienes dicen que cuerpos
deben hablar de qué y qué cuerpos no
pueden hablar de otros temas tu cuerpo
quiero contarle a la audiencia está
atravesado por una cirugía de bypass
gástrico por un problema de salud que no
ha estado vinculado a la gordura aún así
tienes una postura crítica sobre este
tipo de intervenciones has hablado de
una delgadez indeseada y también de una
experiencia gorda que nadie te va a
borrar looks sí de hecho o sea en el
2018 cuando presenté mi libro gorda
vanidosa lo que pasó fue que a los 10
días más o menos me tuve que hacer una
operación un bypass gástrico de
emergencia en general es una operación
que tarda los protocolos si es para
bajar de peso son seis meses pero yo
tenía una enfermedad preexistente que es
enfermedad reflujo gástrico muy agravada
y finalmente o sea tan agravada quiero
terminar un cáncer estomacal o en sus
básicos entonces dada esa situación si
yo si me tenía que hacer un bypass
gástrico no por mi peso y el bypass
gástrico es una de las formas que hoy en
día se promocionan para la reducción de
peso sin embargo el sabido que esta
operación que debe tener más o menos
casi 40 años no empieza en eeuu tiene
graves consecuencias sobre la salud de
las personas que se luego se lo hacen
digamos que acceden quirúrgicamente al
bypass gástrico oa las operaciones
bariátricas y una de las consecuencias
es que no hay demasiado trabajo odia un
trabajo médico de investigación sobre
los efectos a largo plazo sobre esos
cuerpos intervenidos y de hecho hay un
porcentaje muy grande más de un 7 por
ciento de mortalidad por desnutrición
por este tipo de operación entonces está
tan afamada operación en mi caso no fue
para bajar de peso de hecho es
o sea mi corporalidad o mi identidad
corporal sigue siendo el de una persona
gorda porque fui socializado con una
persona gorda y este cuerpo en general
me trae más disforia dios más
incomodidad que digamos que comodidad de
hecho es un cuerpo que lo tengo hace
menos de dos años
no entiendo muy bien cómo funciona tiene
otras limitaciones y aparte de los
efectos del epas fueron
significativamente complejos no después
de la operación es muy muy interesante
esto que planteas lux hablemos ahora
sobre la patologización no de los
cuerpos gordos son considerados faltos
de salud abandonados a veces incluso
hasta depresivos hizo gordo está mal si
sos delgado estás bien no el gordo
aparece como el infractor no aquella
persona que no cumplió con determinadas
normas corporales lux quien es o desde
donde se fijan todos esos patrones
corporales
el tema de los patrones corporales es
sumamente interesante y a la vez
complejo porque si no podría decir bueno
simplemente es la cultura que organiza
digamos estas opresiones y estos
estereotipos y son solo estereotipos de
belleza y solamente eso y sin embargo
podemos ver que convergen una serie de
opresiones específicas o normas
corporales que tienen que ver con
prácticas políticas económicas que
tienen que ver con cuestiones que se
identifican socialmente con la salud
vamos a decir la salud entre unas
comillas bastante complejas entonces
estos estereotipos digamos que aparecen
están atravesados primero por una mirada
que tiende a transformar la realidad es
en el lugar de lo saludable en el lugar
del éxito social o sea lo delgado es no
solo saludable sino que es bello pero
tiene que estar a la vez to feel tiene
que estar en forma es decir que no es
simplemente ser delgado sino que hay
condiciones para ser delgado
al mismo tiempo entonces tose como de
reconocimiento social el gordo es una
persona que es invisibilizada
constantemente desde lo que vamos a
llamar el mercado del deseo de los
cuerpos aunque es visible para ser
señalado como un cuerpo que está mal en
este sentido o sea podemos decir que hay
políticas que atraviesan nuestro cuerpo
y que hacer la corrección corporal hacen
que el cuerpo validado socialmente es un
cuerpo delgado y en esto encontramos
muchas dificultades porque no se trata
solamente de los estereotipos de belleza
en el sentido de bueno cuál es la
circulación de repertorios culturales de
cuerpos delgados y demás sino que es la
reiteración de un estándar hegemónico
donde se trata de personas y género es
decir hombres o mujeres exigen es decir
que no están en ningún tipo de
transición o su identidad no transición
ado
es decir que corresponde a esa identidad
asignada al nacer son personas que son
blancas que geopolíticamente están en
generalmente o sea los rangos digamos
que vamos a decir esos faros no aunque
van a corresponder a la hegemonía tienen
que ver con la relación norte-sur o la
relación europa eeuu inglaterra
a países latinoamericanos al mismo
tiempo esto no tenemos rangos etarios
que van a ser más significativas o sea
las personas jóvenes o sea hay un ideal
de belleza que se sigue que tiene que
ver con ese esa belleza hegemónica
relacionado por lo delgado que esa
belleza tiene que ver con un orden de la
autenticidad es decir cuando uno se
acerca más a ese modelo es más
auténticos más valorados más exitosos
socialmente entonces en todo eso que se
juega o sea cuando hablamos de
opresiones no hablamos simplemente de no
pensar a lo que dice el índice de masa
corporal que es una técnica que muchos
lugares de atención de la salud de
atención nutricional se estar
porque es un número que no refleja
digamos la complejidad de los cuerpos ni
la diversidad corporal porque es esto o
sea no es que todos los cuerpos son
iguales en este sentido hay algo ahí que
se construye alrededor de la persona
digamos de la persona que puede aspirar
digamos a ese lugar hegemónico que es la
delgadez que tiene que ser blanco porque
no hablamos de la cuestión racial hay
una cuestión de género o sea no es lo
mismo ser hombre que ser mujer porque es
binarista absolutamente binarista la
cuestión geopolítica la clase social el
poder adquisitivo la juventud no y todos
estos valores aparecen como valores para
lograr el éxito digamos y un éxito que
tiene que ver en lo social no sea una
persona exitosa está reflejada digamos
con estos patrones
lux algo interesante es que ha planteado
en alguna oportunidad es que el tipo de
propuestas como la del amor propio que
se escucha muchísimo no alcanzan no
entre las experiencias en el marco de lo
que es el activismo gordo se encuentran
el fat body positive no una corriente
que lo que hace es enfatizar que los
cuerpos gordos también son cuerpos
positivos vos planteás que la positiva
acción total le quita cierto poder de
resistencia no que está en la mirada
crítica podrías desarrollar esta idea
que es muy interesante y gracias en el
activismo a bordo lo que tenemos son
varias vertientes acá en latinoamérica
tenemos una experiencia activismo gordo
particular que es una experiencia
bastante híbrida el activismo de la
positiva corporal es un activismo que
así como el activismo crítico nacen a
finales de los años 60 en lo que se van
a llamar las revueltas queer y lo que
tienen para hacer la positividad
corporal es tomar esta estereotipación
de la persona gorda con la persona
enferma
que no es ágil que no es atlética que
come mal que no es bella y trata de
positivizar este estereotipo ahí aparece
no digamos todo el gran movimiento de
modelos plaza saint o modelos de talla
grande en eeuu por ejemplo tenemos ante
julia y otros monsters cuando se llamaba
en un momento que fue la etapa de
grandes revistas como vogue y
cosmopolitan que son revistas de una
mirada recontra hegemónica respecto de
la belleza y que es lo que tiene de
interesante es que es una activista que
promueve digamos esto de el amor propio
lo mismo que naomi igual lo mismo que
sophie mercado lo mismo que acá en
argentina podemos decir prenda mató en
las personas como beltrán joris ver
bueno pero acá en argentina y en
latinoamérica en particular tenemos una
posición un poco más compleja porque
porque el activismo crítico es la parte
en la que yo me escribo por lo menos es
el activo
que no sólo va a tratar de positivizar
esta idea de que el gordo no es enfermo
no es saludable sino que va a ver cuáles
son las
y seno de esa violencia y de su opresión
ósea y una de las raíces es digamos el
sistema de consumo cuando el cuerpo se
transforma en una mercancía muchas veces
es muy complejo o sea que con solo
positivizar lo no transformar ese cuerpo
gordo positividad o como un cuerpo
también no traffic hable en este sentido
habría o sea con la positividad corporal
el horizonte político no hace igualdad
de todos los cuerpos no es la equidad
corporal o la justicia social para todos
los cuerpos sino simplemente entrar en
un abanico de posibilidades en este
punto me parece como central señalar que
es una dificultad es una limitación hizo
un vaciamiento no de la forma
resistencia al del activismo gordo
porque el activismo gordo lo que quiere
es diversidad corporal en un sentido
amplio las que quiere que los gordos
sean mejores que los delgados o mejores
que los chuecos o mejores que no sé las
personas muy altas no absolutamente no
lo que quiere es desmantelar esas
jerarquías socio corporales que existen
y que organ
en nuestra vida porque desde que tenemos
uso de razón estamos pensando
bueno no tengo que hacer dieta para
llegar al verano qué sé yo que sé cuánto
una de las propuestas que sale de la
positividad corporal en conjunto con los
movimientos transfeminismo va a tener
que ver específicamente con la idea del
amor propio y la más propia es un poco
complejo no porque lo más propio implica
un acto individual empoderan t en el
cual yo no se viene un rasgo moralizante
y me dice tu cuerpo está súper bien como
está quererte y esto es algo que la
crítica que yo por lo menos le hago de
mi posición teórica y política como
activista tiene que ver con la falta de
comunidad con la falta de comunidad
porque termina haciendo un acto
absolutamente individual y es un acto
que se debe perpetrar que se debe
perdurar perdón es decir todo el tiempo
bueno estoy sintiendo amor propio nunca
me hago sentir mal nunca puedo sentirme
horrible nunca me puedo despertar no sé
con el pelo mal y digo buche que mal
sino que es un acto que es absolutamente
individual y que pone otro tipo de
normas no sea bueno la norma que es
quererte bueno obligatoriamente bueno te
tenés que querer así como esas buenas y
algunas de las consignas que surge
digamos en los activismos un poco más
críticos trans feministas del mismo
orden que es no alcanza con quererse o
sea no alcanza con esto porque si si
fuera solamente quererse bueno listo ya
está o se es un acto absolutamente
individual y de vuelta volvemos como le
pasa a las personas gordas
al individuo como el único responsable
de circunstancias que son absolutamente
más grandes que tienen que ver con lo
cultural con ideas establecidas y con el
status quo no de los cuadros los looks
moreno muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en entrevista de france 24 ha
sido un placer dialogar contigo no mil
gracias a ustedes a nuestra audiencia
como siempre le invitamos a continuar
informando se en france mit y 4 y en
france mit y 4 punto com
[Música]